hi everyone it's jerry this is game
eight from the 2021 feed a world chess
championship match between magnus
carlson playing on the white end
and yan yapomnishi
going into game 8 carlson leads four to
three in this race to seven and a half
let's have a look
another e4 by carlson
so far throughout this match he's been
alternating d4 then e4
we follow game two another petrov's
defense
in that game play continued with knight
takes e5 the e pawns exchanged
a ram structure was present
in this game
d4 is on board
noted as the modern attack
knight takes e
pressure on the knight some defense of
the knight
both knights now invasive to one another
in both
both posts are addressed by
the queen knights
the knights in this game are quick to
observe from the sidelines and after
these eight moves we have on board
a symmetrical position
both kings still in the center on an
open file so naturally what do you do
in this game white castles and
black
doesn't castle
important not to
just copy
white's last move
this would be a problem
why
because of that
white's hitting here
and there
how do you deal with it
the only way to stop the loss of
material would be to play f5 but that's
not without its issues this would be a
serious positional concession
e5 is now a big hole
as soon as that
weakness is created in black's camp
this is
one of the thoughts that should run
through a player's mind
which minor piece exchanges
are
benefiting me which ones will be
desirable
without question it would be the dark
square bishops
this is the bad guy this is the good guy
this good guy
watches over e5
and without this bishop around
white would be able to look forward to
pivoting about
on
the e5 square
let me put some moves on to show
how white can maybe
try and take advantage of the e5 square
step one
get in tension with this bishop
maybe even you get into an ending
and here you go
there goes the rook
you can't get rid of it with the pawn
and if it's so annoying you have to get
rid of it with the piece
well now there's a new issue
that's not just any past pawn
it's a connected pass pawn
super valuable
i don't know the assessment of this
position
i just know that white's playing for
you know
white is in the driver's seat
19 moves down the road
the main point
castles queen h5 f5 problem on e5
and it seems like it could be exploited
all right
so what does black come up with
creative move without question
h5
about 17 minutes invested into that move
well this certainly keeps the queen out
of h5 the rook's now defending that
square uh but a question here is can't
black play queen h4 if if this was
looking pretty good after castles
striking at these two
uh why can't this queen play to h4 right
now and do similar striking at h2 and d4
well
it's not the same
why not well after g3 queen takes d4
white can get the pawn back with bishop
c3 and that pawn is one back it's not
just any pawn that's the heart
of black's king side structure
white is doing excellent in this
position maybe a check maybe win the
pawn maybe even win the exchange right
right even if you move this pawn isn't
this rook dead
soon
these bishops cover a lot of ground
all right my point here is that this is
met with g3 and we could get the pawn
back after queen takes d4
so it is
h5
and now
white
has a good think about 40 minutes was
spent on carlson's 10th move
he's experiencing some difficulties
he has some problems to solve
one move later
this may appear
and it could be a bit more effective so
let's say for example we go with the
most natural looking move
rookie one check
best would be to
go uncastled
now
the king is defending g7 in the event of
this
queen h4 g3 chop
bishop c3 isn't working anymore
the king's defending that point
so
what do we do
about queen h4
if you develop the queen right
there's this you could play g3 or h3
it's unclear this position
black's up upon it's not like white is
losing but yeah certainly unclear
also
let's say white attempts to
defend this pawn
preparing to meet queen h4 with g3
well now the queen slides in here
nearby there's h4
the bishops are pointing near the king
the queen is pointing near the king and
this rook can soon be pointing near the
king after this exchange
do you really want to as white
underdeveloped to drive the queen back
this queen stands better than the white
queen
this is still nearby
black can castle by hand healthy moves
f6 king f7 rooks are connected
one final note
if the queen is allowed to go here and
you play h3 instead staying out of the
way of this pawn advancing and creating
tension
to pry open the h file
black would be winning with this
sacrifice
not only threatening this
familiar four move checkmate pattern
bishop h2 bishop g3
queen h2 queen f2
but also
queen takes bishop
so
what does he come up with
not the most natural move
queenie one
this is rare
this battery
is showing up
uh it's it's rare to you know it's it's
more common to see
this sort of battery right in in some
positions where you're attempting to
exchange off a fee and cut out bishop
but the idea here is to exchange off the
bishop
in this way
king f8 follows this was the big problem
in many of those variations i was
highlighting right with the queen coming
out to h4 so he's trying to get rid of
this guy
very clever
bishop b4 follows
this again
uh is a bad for good bishop exchange you
don't have to have this
uh e5 squares a hole for that to be the
case we can determine good bad bishops
by this structure alone in the center
so from here we have queen e7
whitey likes to keep the queens on board
only a dark square bishop exchange
happens
at this stage
if we're exchanging queens
and trying to play for a win in this
position
on one hand white can say
i have the better bishop but black is
saying i have a really active king in
the center on a dark stable square and
you're never kicking me off of this post
this is an even position
so the queens stay on board white's
going to try
and
uh cause a problem for the king
and in a way this rook right it's gonna
be maybe a little bit tricky for the
rook to get activated
so first things first vacay e1 mission
accomplished on this square
it's opened for the white rooks
rook to e8 rook a to e1
rook to h6 and given just one more move
black will
be perfectly fine
so for example
let's say if white secures strengthens
the queen side structure defends d4
this rook plays here and it's likely all
rooks are off and we have a queen bishop
ending alone
is it enough having only this better
bishop probably not
white tries to cause some problems he
sees this
plan and says
i'm going to give your rook a
responsibility
some pressure on h5
not so fast
some support of d5 this frees up the
queen to challenge the white
queen one rook exchange
open file
white ducks the exchange
you really don't get anywhere if the
if we have this ending
too simplified
no great
not enough of an imbalance is present
in this position
so the queens stick around queen e3
threatening mate bishop d7
flight square for white black now clamps
down on white's king side structure
having this pawn on h4 may one day pave
the way for a perpetual check pivoting
on f4 and c1
continually striking at the king
all right
that's a ways down the road
from here c4 some tension on the queen
side
considered one of the best moves in the
engine's eyes is to play you ready for
this one g5
this opens up g7 for the king and also
hints at maybe playing g4 i had to look
at some lines where the queen goes
hunting for these pawns over here
and that's where black can consider g4
and
h3 and work with these three attacking
the king
g5
not the most human move of course
you have to calculate what's going to
happen after this and then queen e5
this is now a target
seems like this queen is intolerable
you'd have to get rid of it do you have
a good answer to this one this double
attack you'd have to calculate many
moves deep the computer assesses it as
about equal
all right i don't want to go down that
line i believe the train of thought here
well one line of thought is i don't want
to have to babysit upon on d5
instead i'll saddle you
with an isolated pawn and i'll be okay
with inviting this bishop on this
diagonal pointing towards my king
this is what was played in the game
black captures we have the recapture
and next up move 21 this is where
there's
a mistake by black
uh you'll notice that with the bishop on
c4 there's now a new key move available
to white
with the queen
and that key move is queen a3 where she
really does function like a queen
striking in multiple directions
targeting a7
unprotected
the move played in the game is b5
now considered best is king g8
if queen e7 follows
right trying to take advantage of the
weakness of the last move
king's no longer there
black can meet this with bishop to e6
and
we're either gonna have a bishop
exchange or a queen exchange
no time to go hunting for this this guy
would fall
and also no time to take the bishop
because the queen would fall
considered best is the queen exchange a
bishop exchange and this rook ending is
a draw with some accurate move
it's important to play rook h6 in this
position and go from here
trying to defend with g5
that runs into some problems with rook
g4
not easy to defend this pawn
this there's that
and even if you defend it from the side
there's still this one
if you enter a king and pawn ending
black would be losing this pawn gets
hunted g3 is in this pawn runs outside
pass pawn for the win
so
king g8 not played
b5
bishop's under fire where should it go
nowhere
queen a3 hits with check
and
this queen is ready to go into pac-man
mode
targeting 8 a7 and then the unprotected
bishop
what do you do is black
if you block the check
and secure the bishop
you still don't have to react to this
threat
white would still be able to take on a7
if pawn takes bishop black gets mated
queen a8
you take the pieces when they block
so
in the game it's king g8
queen takes a7
what follows is queen d8 securing the
bishop
and stopping any back rank checks so
white is now currently up upon
has to address
the pressure on the bishop
if black tried something else instead of
this one let's say
a desperado sacrifice bishop takes h3
all right if you just take right back
maybe you take like this or insert a
check first
here's how white can follow
this is a nice move
queen takes f7
queen takes queen
can be met with rook check
then you get the queen you're up a pawn
you're on this
and white is
yeah
up upon
very active pieces
so
the bishop takes on h3 isn't quite
working
here's another cool
uh
variation
let's look at this check if the
if bishop takes h3 instead of this queen
d8
here's another interesting variation
let's say check was played first
and then
bishop takes on f7
this is an interesting position because
black has only one move
which draws
and white in reply
only has
one move
which draws
what is the
what is the draw here
here it is
rook g6
that's this is a draw now
if white captures the rook
look at this
the rook is hit
and we're threatening mate
black wins
there's only one move that draws for
white
what is it
it's rook h8
the queen comes to the back rank gives a
check
gives another check
forces the king here so now there's no
longer a pin
now you could take the rook
and finally take the bishop
those are some pretty slick lines
um yeah i certainly didn't
find all of that i have a good friend in
stock fish 14
but
yeah
neat
in my estimation
uh okay
queen d8 in this game no desperado
sacrifice
on the defensive is black bishop backs
off
secure square still observing f7
rook
d6 follows
the rook is now improved gives the queen
a responsibility
this guy is so good black is saying i
need to get rid of it
so bishop e6
both bishop and rook
are exchanged and we have a queen
ending
with wipe up an extra pawn
first centralization
queen a5 what's the plan for white in
general
the main one is don't allow perpetual
check
and try and keep your queen in a good
position to watch over
any of your pawns that are unprotected
so each side goes hunting for pawns
queen takes c
check the f pawn is picked up the e pawn
falls white's now up two pawns
and let's see how white tries to convert
this first
staying very central with the queen
this is a very effective post
in combating a perpetual check
we can see that because after the move
b3 there isn't a fear of g3
check
and queen e1 check we have that one
covered
we also have the e3 check covered
a great post for the queen
b3 what's the idea
black
white is okay with giving up the a pawn
it's captured
and white hunts the b-pawn first with
the check there you go
still up two pawns
back to central stopping any checks
altogether
some repositioning to now d2
support of the pawns is white now ready
to advance like so
i thought
in this position maybe you can play
queen to d1 but i found this next move
by carlson instructive here's another
neat post
by the queen where she observes
e1 and c1 which are necessary
follow-up checks for the queen if black
wants to get a perpetual check in there
right
g3 and then e1
or if the queen is on
f4 and c1
yeah the queen has them covered
queen does a good job on
a dark square and controlling
uh
these dark squares
uh she covers a blend of squares both
color complexes but more dark than light
being on a dark square so
okay queen f4 king g1
and in the end the queen decides to go
back home just like black did a bit ago
and from this post she's stopping any
perpetual checks and keeping a watchful
eye over both pawns that's the main
idea and
uh she's very effective from d1
so queen e3 king h1
uh also she watches over the g4 square
in the event that black tries to create
some tension
she may have the
option to capture on g4
black plays g5
white runs
black continues to push
and
white captures with the pawn
so this structure is going to be broken
down a little bit
right after this we have h3
if white tries to keep the structure as
is
capturing with the queen
this would be a draw
because now
white is subjected to checks on the back
rank with queenie1
queen e5
queen e1 and if you want to get out of
this perpetual check you would have to
play
g3 but now
you would be vulnerable on the second
rank
2 queen b2
queen c1
queen d2 and if you want to stop these
checks you'd have to block with the
queen but then there's this check
this is a drawn ending
so
careful
don't leave the back rank
white captures in this game
with the pawn on g4
black gets in h3
and after queen f3
this game goes no further
black resigns
the queen
is
perfectly placed on f3
defending all pawns
and
securing the king
against any perpetual check ideas
so for example if play continued
from here after queen f3 let's say
there's this check
and black gives another check
eventually they're going to run out
and we get to see just how effective the
queen is on f3
no checks along the rank you can't get
to f1 or h1 because of the queen
no checks here the pawn blocks
even if the pawn moves you still can't
get on that diagonal e6 is covered
the only way is to maybe get on the h
file but you're still two moves out and
white don't forget has some ways to
improve their queen
giving check may be forcing a queen
exchange
let me let me try some attempt from this
position
let's say the king goes here
sidestepping any
any great
uh
great
white
uh queen checks here so let's say g6
um let me make another
passing move it's not the greatest move
but just to illustrate one variation you
can have a queen exchange like that
the main point at the end of the day is
to recognize
the very strong post
of the white queen in this final
position
well not the final position of the game
but we can easily get to this point
right here where there again everything
is defended
and there's no perpetual checks
and white will easily be able to make
progress running with
one of the pawns and forcing a queen
exchange somehow or another
it's uh
an impossible task for black but he goes
no further queen f3 final move in this
game eight and a huge score
for carlson now going into the rest
today
uh
five to three
going into game nine
nippon nishi only has three more i would
say three more tries three more games
with the white pieces and he needs to
make up
a lot of ground
fast so
we will see what happens it is still not
over a big edge for carlson clearly
up two clear points
tailed the tape on this one
there we go
it was an edge for carlson throughout
and right here after bishop takes c4
boom
b5 that was the big
mistake not the blunder but the
yeah this one is the one that registered
as the mistake
the blunder later on i think was
considered rook d6 but the main issue in
this game was the
b5 advance instead of putting the king
on g8
at the end of the day what do we have
a couple inaccuracies for carlson
a mistake and a blunder for
team black
nippomnishi
and
average centipond loss of 20 and 32
for each
okay as usual feel free to leave any
feedback to this video in the comments
section below hope you enjoyed it
and maybe took a thing or two away
that's all for now take care bye
you